look fam i'll say this if you deaf blind
dumb mentally handicapped start a
podcast
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
how does this look all right they look
cool dog
i wouldn't say cool you look pretty cool
that's a lie
you look like the flyest [ __ ] you know
you got a body like a [ __ ] that's
stretched out
no i knew i really yeah you got that you
had that [ __ ] dumper on you
no i don't you built like a stressed out
[ __ ] dog you look cool though dog
stressed no no you're not stressed you
don't look stressed
really that's the look i'm going for
really stressed
kind of achieving it i feel like my body
style is more like that gingerbread man
you think like boxy i'm thinking more
like you get that you get them
fat haunches they get like that the
little people ass like you never met a
little person with a flat ass
haunted all they're all see i got that
style right
i don't think so man like i'm torso
heavy man
oh that's me too no he got a chest you
don't have a chest i even have white
hands and feet like that
yo white feet yeah i got sweet feet too
you know if i smell my hands dude i've
always had this thing
since i was little if i smell my hands
they smell like uh
syrup syrup oh dad you like that smells
like syrup
yeah like mr buttersworth or whatever
that smells like
car oil that even work on cars
what's your smell like nick yeah you
don't work it's just my aftershave and i
actually smell my hands all the time so
much so that i told her editor joe if i
smell my hands make sure that's not on
camera but i always go like this i'm
just thinking
why do you smell your hands all the time
it smells like aftershave and i like it
damn that's addiction i'll tell you what
i will do
sometimes when i spill a little gas on
my hand i'm like
when because i like to smell that finger
for the rest of it i love that
oh i love that gut or like a fresh paint
when does that say you smell that spray
paint daddy god i love it
i love that man to it dude yeah when i
was young somebody spray painted
i was unconscious or whatever in this
park and somebody spray painted like a
bunch of spray paint like in my butt
crack and it like stuck together for a
long time
stick your cheeks together yeah just
it's real you don't realize how
dangerous a lot of that pain is i caught
my son smelling a sharpie
i said dog quit doing that he said why i
said
you need all the brain cells bubba
you're too young to be doing this
he said but i saw you doing it it's
different yeah it's different
how about i have these nicotine the
rogue nicotine around the house
and when i first started doing it he's
like dad what is this
you know his my girl was like it's bad
for you shouldn't be using that
but then when she was gone i was like
it's dad's medicine so now
coming back dad here's your medicine i'm
like thanks buddy no
yeah dang dude now that sounds dangerous
yeah probably not the best thing to do
yeah thinking your kid is running around
giving you medicine
and that's uh and what is that nicorette
nicotine nicotine
what's in that box oh i don't what is in
this box what's in the box what's in the
box
that was a gift actually we opened on uh
theo's unboxing challenge but there was
something in there for brendan as well
so
[ __ ] we're [ __ ] tired bro you didn't
sleep last night
yeah so [ __ ] eight hours it's because
you're it's cause you're off caffeine
dude who told you get off caffeine what
warlock till you get off caffeine
why are you listening all these dumb yet
i got too much caffeine
get in here thanks homie yelp you know a
lot of men they were
meeting other men on yelp
really like leaving reviews but in code
word yeah like this roast beef is fire
yeah and then leave their cell phone
number yeah yeah come get this salad or
something you know and it's like a
furniture shop
who wants this foot long yeah if i could
give six stars i would
oh yeah will you look up yelp uh
it's all in code secret gay or
secret i don't know if that's gonna pop
up maybe just google secret yelp talk
let's see there you go secret lounge
closed oh dawg i only got a massage the
other day did you
bro these bassoo how many people were
just one person it was one
one asian lady i felt bad first you oh
you you big
yeah i'm pretty big but then dude
they'll do anything for some change
coming out of covid dog
oh i mean you'd be a little less you're
lying
at least at least let me be surprised if
you touch my piece yeah
like they just they need that cash done
they'll go peace first yeah
it's just out in the open man they had
oh this one little lady she'll climb
down your throat and kick the mucus
off your freaking walls in there i'll
pay good hardcore
dude dude this lady will pull one of
your tonsils out with her dang freaking
uh
i feel bad for this little root gripper
i feel bad she's doing work
sweating and [ __ ] it's really wild man
and a lot of people from other
from vietnam and other countries love
gardening they love being in the soil
yeah you know digging that back what is
this snake am i gonna get
[ __ ] it's no snakes or anything it's
it's just a nice poisonous tree frog or
something no it's a really nice gift
somebody gave that to you
oh that's nice can i read the card
brandon i left one c out of the thick
boy because you've been looking slim my
boy
thanks so he's a liar thanks for
everything you do sir collect a lot aka
sir collect a lot yep that's
that's his handle homemade action
figures everything you guys do oh
damn a little theo vaughn one doggie let
me see
that is legit the other one is you
where's the other one you just set it
down oh [ __ ]
oh wow mine's neat
it's pretty dope can we show uh
mark's camera yeah
i mean he made mine through yours hiding
it
dang good ears
wow you look so jewish on this
go look at this by jewish you mean juicy
dude oh dude
heavy on the ew dog i can't give that to
my son now you know
oh wow you really got it up dude cut it
up dog
that's awesome tell him to meet me at
[ __ ] 250 dog
i just benched 4 25 yesterday stupid
[ __ ]
for what up dude that's not in nashville
daddy we could do you went out there
playing grab ass in nashville
let me [ __ ] send it to you nick we
could do four how much was it
425 the 25's negligible though
well i did 405 too easy so i went to
425.
we could do about it what about colon
curve how much you bench
um i don't bench that much but like my
like
i don't really bench but okay ever dude
unbelievable story huh what's your bench
[ __ ] probably 240 245
yeah at least man and then what about
when you're on the sauce though i'm
checking 315.
no not 315. probably 270. i always had
strong
bench dude you find me i'd be pushing up
dawg
we actually had a cats in the wild of
chin and uh old pork rind working out
together
oh wow look at these
way to pump him up got him
uh that he's dead lifting i just sent to
nick he's that was that
those are 55s it looks like that's a lot
of [ __ ] white 55-55 that's what look
at this man
that's 500 something 530 maybe
oh my goodness is he really gonna do
this
we'll do it dog take the glasses off and
do it
and he has no shoes on and he's asian
what
[Music]
that's actually why chin isn't here
today because he actually pulled
something in his back that's why he
wasn't able to
make sense i wish jin could do that i
wish jin could do that
now i'm not trying to one up that kid i
did 600 the other day 600
pounds yeah why are y'all doing that man
you guys are definitely don't need to be
doing that much weight i don't think
well you know someone walked by like oh
i bet you can't do this i'm like
say what and then it's on doug and then
it's on
dude y'all are [ __ ] i'll do [ __ ] 6
10. you can do [ __ ] you're going to
nashville and [ __ ]
cry about it i'll do 610 in nashville
i'll do 612 out here dude
i don't give a [ __ ] you will you stop
working with that trainer that's getting
that ass right
listen to music there i am right there
spotting you because you need it
i wish that was you dog let's mark the
body harley son
that guy has the same hair as my mom
dude
how much is that 425 it's not that much
yeah probably could do more i remember i
used to do a pretty good bit man
on what um
on chest and legs you used to have a bit
on chest
i used to do a pretty good bit of weight
oh i thought you said you had a bit on
it
no i don't have anything like that i
feel like you'd be good at squatting
with that ass you're building a squat
yeah
i used to squat some my back went out
dude i was moving a television
it was when they first had uh big
screens
and i was moving one ones not like today
were like
thin like the real thick heavy screens
yeah
and oh dude we were pushing this thing
across a field one of our neighbors
moved into a different neighbor
and we couldn't find like a trolley or
anything like that and so
we're just trying to literally push it
with our shoulders across this field
dude
but that fire they fired your ass up and
then it was so hard
dislocated my back god damn yeah
jesus christ must've been a vizio
i don't remember what it was it was
awesome do you have flat screens in
nashville because you pretty
you're a frugal man we got a flashlight
you're the guy with those big
old-school tvs you gotta turn the dial
and [ __ ] i got a 58 inch in there right
now all right daddy don't flex i'm too
hard 58.
you close that thing here bud you're
about
whatever
that did you know that dog is the same
dog as the one from full house
comet oh really yep bud and he
just a star actor in hollywood i thought
he got canceled for saying the n-word
i wish i had the crew of that doghouse
god damn better help you need it
jesus we need it i need it who's on it
i'm on it
i've been on it man one time i had a
flat tire and i didn't know what to do
about to take my own life
what did i do i got on my phone i got on
better help
and i took care of myself mentally so
that i didn't have to feel weird
or anything and i could change my tire
and change my ways praise god so what
i'm telling you about now is better help
there's a broad range of expertise
available if you don't know if you want
somebody who's chatty or quiet
you want a listener or a suggester an
advisor
or a friend better help has all types of
counselors for mental health it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available
get help jesus christ
look at yourself better help want you to
start living a happier life
today that's right visit betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com k-a-t-s join the over 1 million
people who have taken
charge of their mental health it's your
brain
change it and the rest of your life will
change
i got this necklace on this is tungsten
actually 100
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and the king and the sting listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
kats don't feel ashamed if you need help
i get it
you can if you need it warmer weather
guys it's time for it and you're feeling
it
a lot of people are having heat stroke
and people dying in their cars asleep
but what i'm trying to tell you right
now is that you want a shoe that can
last you
all year long and look good at all times
and i just got mine i wore them on the
plane yesterday and they
were great i'm talking about all birds
that's right all birds new tree runners
yup as we start to take steps towards
normalcy
we all need to come out the trees no
better way to do it than all birds
tree runners the tree runners are
breathable machine
washable and made with responsibly
sourced
eucalyptus tree fiber so
jeepers who could want anything more the
fact that you can wash them
is amazing they're simple and versatile
design uh
you know i would say they look good
almost with a suit or even
maybe even with shorts i haven't worn
mine with shorts yet
the tree runner is carbon neutral thanks
to sustainable practices
like using natural materials and
purchasing carbon offsets
they're certified as a public benefit
corporation keep things light and breezy
with the
all birds tree runner discover your
perfect pair
at allbirds.com that's a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot-com um i've
i've only worn them for about a day and
a half but it's been a sheer joy
oh here's a guy right here as a question
no this is actually
so today we've got a lot of relationship
advice but we wanted to follow up
because
this is a guy from like two years ago oh
yeah i remember
oh he's smoking we remember he's like
all undercover shrunken weed yeah let's
see what he said back then
gang gang buzz buzz oh yeah relationship
advice i've been married for
25 years you have to think about that
he's guessing well he's been great
helped me get through anxiety i'm still
dealing with some [ __ ]
so i've been uh smoking some weed oh
yeah
but i got caught before doing that and
she wasn't happy about it but
i thought it helps i just started again
and i haven't told her yet she told me
last time that i
should tell her before i try to do
anything like this
so question is should i tell her
it seems to help with anxiety
or should i just well you're gonna have
anxiety either way
dude i'm having anxiety waiting for you
to get through this sentence dude i will
say this though
that guy looks like the canadian tony
hawk first of all dude
uh tony bulk
dude you ever seen tony hawk tony hall
yeah dude
tony that's a thin dude but this dude
what happened to him nikki passed away
oh well you guys gave him different
level of advice i'm pretty sure brendan
told him to just get divorced
wow you know out of shooters too and we
just wanted to check in with them and
see uh
what oh we're calling him now he's
nervous i call his name
i call him tony hulk
there he is big mark what up baby hey
how's it going
sponsored by monster what's up thank you
get up what's chris doing here
i love it man you got some whiskey in
the background there my man what is that
uh buffalo chase i've got crown royal
salted caramel smart man
oh yeah what's that other one
yeah i can't find that boy hey man
brother where are you at you still in
the garage or they let you back in
no i got my own little corner in the
house here getting myself
did did our advice help you at all i
forget what we what we said exactly
no you said something about eating ass
or yep oh
i'm sorry man i'm sorry about that maybe
when she's 20
yeah i'm sorry if i had that advice then
it probably would help but
sorry man yeah it's more of a yeah i
think eating ass is probably more of a
children's game
yeah i'm a little too old for that so
did you did your wife catch you uh
smoking the reefer
yeah yeah let's see i came clean to her
one day
i took uh oh i don't know whose advice
was to come clean i
theo told me to keep that little secret
because i did kind of enjoy that he was
right he called that
he was right on the money with that yeah
it's funny yeah i said
it's fun hiding the truth from people
it's fun hiding the truth from people
that you love
yeah and then uh also i was
mentioning with nick and i said i
imagine i treat my wife like theo treats
nick
you lash out for people you like the
most oh
oh you hit your wife too yeah
that was once and that was in the
parking lot and that was an
accident and you for you and he's
forgiven him you look like a working man
dude you got some
you got some some dirt on those nails my
man
you're a working man these are uh
these are my hands after i clean up
after work oh gotcha
hey man brother so yeah machine work
welding and uh
run a plas table things like that so and
you're up in canada eh
no iowa oh okay but you said
your wife eventually now she wants you
to smoke weed so you don't snap
at her yeah oh she came around
full circle dude yeah she now she's
all for it at first she's upset by it
that's just uh
the way people are around here it's deep
do you still get anxiety
or has that has the weight taken yeah
yeah i get it all time i just
fight it all day because i don't smoke
at work obviously i wouldn't be able to
do my job
but uh yeah yeah and then you get home
and puff out mom and smoke and
i only gotta fight it for 12 hours a day
i like that man and look i also say this
about marijuana
it'll make you it definitely i think it
promotes a more healthy sexual active
lifestyle
oh you think yeah i think you're more
likely to bone down on your spouse if
you're
uh geeked up on a little bit of that
smoke
i'd probably agree with that i guess oh
that's what i'm saying
dude it'll make somebody's it just makes
somebody's tits feel better
i feel like it a little more if you got
a hit of that gas
and your lungs maybe i feel like it
really just makes somebody's body feel
just
it makes them feel different it's like
they're different it's like it's not the
same
wife you've had or husband you've had
for a long time and they make homemade
whatever you want
like a uh intruder or something oh that
makes sense and then mark had one more
thing to tell us the last time he was on
uh brendan uh made fun of his turkey
neck
oh yeah what yeah
i'm sorry man i still got a little bit
there but dude i told you
you asked i made fun of your neck i'm
sorry dude that's typical bernie you
should listen to more of what you
suggest to people
i feel like it worked he's still married
look at him he's crushing that's true
actually he's doing good
and you're down how much uh 58 pounds oh
what's up doug let's go baby congrats
brother congrats man and where'd you
where'd you notice you lost it the most
is there a place in your body where you
see it missing the most
uh pretty much everywhere my legs are a
lot better i've been
yeah baby doing some weights and things
like that too yeah
good for you man good for you and you
joined like we helped
you join a fitness plex or something did
you join a uh neighborhood meet
a group or something meet in the park
planet fitness oh i got i got a speed
bag weights and stuff here in my
oh man my little room am i getting the
helmet
at home gym dad i like that man yeah
good for you man well congrats brother
keep smoking that reef and losing the
weight man thanks
high and skinny bruh that'd be your new
nickname high and skinny
high and skinny unless you get the
munchies late at night that could be a
problem
yeah now how do you fend that off when
you get all uh you you really
you just want to tongue down a bag of
tater slices what do you do i turned the
cookie monster
oh yeah i i had that real bad for a long
time but i've been able to
control it now damn disciplinary
freedom there you go if i got so fat
lazy i couldn't smoke dope so i think
i'm more active now than i was
before wow what a success story man
that's it man i feel like dr phil
oh yeah i know it's not it's not the
answer someday i'll
work at getting therapy or something
when
yeah but get to it you know but now
maybe you seem to be doing all right on
your own man yeah and plus
yeah sometimes you just gotta just smoke
a little bit of dope man and keep going
yeah life's all good brother well thanks
for calling man yeah thanks mark
yeah good proud to see you look at
losing so much weight man
congratulations dude
thanks a lot guys hey can i get a shout
out to somebody yeah oh yeah you know
your dealer
jolly roll yeah that's our guy man
i never heard about it until i saw kane
in this thing now i [ __ ] love the guy
he's great he's a legend he's crushing
it right now he's back on tour man
people are singing his songs he doesn't
see it anymore
he just gets out to put the mic to the
crowd and they sing for him over a
billion views on youtube
wow yeah yeah so thanks for
turning me on to that guy yeah man
that's our boy
you're more than welcome have a good day
man smoke some smoke some weed and
listen jelly roll for us my man yeah
stay well man stay healthy baby
see ya gang wow man
look at that little body shaming goes a
long ways man
yeah that's how i got my fattest in
shape really yup a little body shaming
what happened
uh someone called me fat who was it
just some random dude at the gym damn
i know like the wild west man i thought
you'd be in better shape i was like i'll
[ __ ] you dog
but that [ __ ] worked dude you never know
what'll work that's what i'm saying
that's called
i told him he has a turkey goblin look
at him down 55 pounds
that's a good point man let's tell this
guy something yeah he needs some help
too he's got some relationship
or a relationship vice question hey uh
meg ryan and rosie o'donnell my name is
dylan
and i'm coming to you guys for a little
bit of relationship advice
moved out to california i've been here
for
about seven months i met this girl we
kicked it off right away
started only seeing each other right
away so i've been into black girls
for a while not sure why it's just
my thing that's that bottom lip bro um
she was the first
girl that was black that i would call my
girlfriend i've been with other black
girls before but
never call them my girls we started off
really good
um probably the first four months we
didn't really have any problems
and then every time we hung out we would
start arguing she would have shown how
to
do about stuff that doesn't even matter
oh yeah so i guess i'm just
asking do a is that just a black girl
thing
is it a california thing do i keep going
after black girls do i
not gang gang baby uh
i mean i think it just depends have you
dated black girl
i went over to a black girl's house one
time and i think had sex
but you so you didn't date one no it's
different when you sign up for the whole
game i
i don't know if that's a la thing i
don't think it's an la thing man
but also four months that's when [ __ ]
gets real dawg
yeah that's true i don't know if that's
something four months is that
the honeymoon phase everything's all
good you're like all right she farted
not big deal you look over a few things
next thing you know you know she's
spraying his hair he has cornrows
and [ __ ] yeah yeah that's true dude and
he's wearing iverson jerseys to sleep
you know like some of that it could get
a little warm
and [ __ ] yeah yeah he's got like he's
wearing slippers to work
you know what i'm saying like it could
get a little wild i think
i think uh you know i don't know
i don't think it's a black thing i think
it's that girl's thing you're you're
just not a match doug
right and now that's all it is yeah i
think if you date another black girl for
four months and it happens again then it
could you could start
to speculate you know that it's a herb
yeah maybe you just don't get along with
them it's an urban phenomenon
you know but i think it's um
it's dope dude get out there and try
some different you know get out there
and get a taste of that urbanity
you know and see what's going on in the
mix but yeah black girls also
they're more vivacious so i think that's
a normal statement man
meaning black girls get more turnt up
and more like
you know they'll go from [ __ ] zero to
negative 16 in a [ __ ] moment you know
that's tina's two though man i think
it's a lot of yeah
i think if you get outside of more the
the only way you get that in the white
community i think is if you go with a uh
ginger those ginger got some fire in
there they get a little sparky
yeah yeah they get a little off a little
bit especially around leap year and [ __ ]
they'll get a little [ __ ] vibey dawg
they'll leave the car running
you know so i think yeah
but yeah i mean if you get invited to
like essence festival or something dude
you're probably gonna get [ __ ] shot
yeah probably lay low my man yeah i
wouldn't get crazy
you start taking vacations atlanta lay
low you know
yeah dude if you find yourself in
[ __ ] jamaica but not at a resort
you know like then you might yeah i just
don't want to see you get uh
you know i just don't want to see
something crazy happen to you you know
yeah man you'll be smart man also mix it
up look at this little freaking one yeah
here's something right here that's right
we try this out
hey theo hey brendan it's savannah from
out here in southern idaho
um i have a little bit of a debate club
slash relationship advice for you
yes i'll move in with you me and my
boyfriend of four years
just decided to part ways
after i was ready to be wifed up and he
decided
he didn't want to wife me up so i'm
going through a little bit of a rut
wondering if i should just keep it tight
and look for that forever or if i should
have a whole face
so debate club who phase or
keep it tight and look for that ride or
die i'm only 24 so it's not a huge deal
right now i know
everybody's telling me not to rush it
but i want to see what you guys think
so thank you and brennan i'd love to see
you again we met a few years ago at the
wise guys comedy club and that was
pretty cool
um theo i'd love to see you for the
first time so get your ass to the west
coast
thanks guys gang gang buzz buzz dude 24
[ __ ] horde up for 5 000 alex
i think if you 24 i think uh
what was the question again i think he's
sliding some dallas cowboys dms you feel
me like get wild girl
especially that body like start living
man it's a disgrace if you don't
well i don't know much but i would say
this that i think the chances of you
getting out there and having a nice
time outside of a relationship we're
probably pretty good
i think you could meet a good farming
man too
especially if she's out there where she
said idaho yep
get out there in nampa they got a place
called nampa out there where they make
uh
tomatoes not tomatoes but um squat not
squash but um
potatoes no sugar beets oh those are
nice
i i think she should get out of idaho
and get to vegas or somewhere and
dude just let loose girl she's growing a
set of sugar beets of her own yeah you
know what i'm saying i can't tell if
it's the video the way that yeah
lighting is on the video hush puppies or
some dads
i can't tell you that's what i'm
thinking dude she has some
bongers yeah
what do you mean i could have a baby i
could have a baby
she's the type of girl chin would take
out and black out on sake oh yes
it looks like each one of her brush just
ate a big sandwich dude that's what it
looks like dude he has some definitely
corn fed hitters oh she's got those
jersey mics
baby you feel me mike check
dude i would say yelling to each one of
those yeah
we can hear every girl i would double
dribble and smell them honey
i'd freaking try to hide one of those in
you know my mouth saying and then
freaking call the cops on myself and i
choked to death
breaking news uh theo just added a show
on boise
yeah what about you neck nipple what do
you think when you see that girl huh
honestly i'm thinking of moving to
indiana now i don't know wherever she is
go to indiana that'll help indiana
you'll fit in there
she's in idaho bro yeah it's only 14
hours away
i will forrest gump my way to wherever
she is yeah she's a baddie 24
too man here she is about to fight this
is her ex-boyfriend right here
let's get in some king at her stinging i
wonder why he wasn't ready man she
didn't give us enough information he
might be 24.
he's like um what no girl i don't know
that's still dumb though 24 would be
stupid she said she met you before you
should give me my shot wise guys man
i mean ring a bell no i you know he's
pretty girl i don't know dude
i don't know there's not a lot of girls
at my show so you think i'd remember
it's a real cockfest right sounds
skeptical that's what i'm saying
there's not a lot of like i've seen yes
it's a lot of me it's a bro
crowd dude so i i don't remember you
know i guess i actually have a lot of
ladies i think they come to my shows but
yeah mine's been getting better i doubt
that
hey you're probably watching us at home
and
and uh struggling to do that and i feel
you
but look if you're watching us you want
a little snack you want a pizza bite
you know what i'm saying you want a damn
toffee you want a damn uh
you know a nicorette or something uh
steak what can help you is grubhub
grubhub is the difference between you
sitting there hungry and you having
something
inside of you that tastes good and feels
good
imagine something sliding down your neck
right now that brings you joy
and i'm not talking about a sloth or a
slug talking about someone on the inside
of your body i'm talking about food
treats
that's right grubhub works hard to serve
restaurants so they can work hard to
serve you
yup they even have great local hot spots
if you want to eat
local they can do it today grubhub is
doing a little extra
to serve panera get a free delivery perk
on your first order from panera
of 15 or more yep that free delivery
perk
order through the grubhub app or online
grubhub
helping you get fed through restaurants
in your area grubhub we serve
restaurants
so you started your own online store and
you want to sell something you're
selling a necklace
you're selling a neck warmer you're
selling a damn uh toffee you and your
your wife or your ex-wife made a new
toffee and y'all trying to get rid of it
and you in that sugar treat racket but
you got to get rid of it you got to sell
it you have to sell
that's the thing you need to do luckily
ship station makes it easy
yep with ship station it's simple to
import manage and ship your orders
out fast quick ordering quick shipping
import orders from any sales channel
that's right no matter
where you're selling amazon etsy or your
own website
you want to get rid of a funnel cake you
want to get rid of a dang
catalytic converter or something hell
you want you found some human
bones in your yard get rid of them ship
station you'll get access to amazing
discounts with major carriers
including usps fedex and
you'll even get access to amazing
discounts
from major carriers including ups fedex
and usps with ship stations small
businesses
can now access the same deals and
discounts that fortune 500 companies
have been using
for decades just use our offer code kats
to get a 60 day free trial that's
shipstation.com
and our offer code k-a-t-s for a 60-day
two-month
free trial give it a shot make ship
happen
but i'll say this i met uh claudia the
other night the one that
chen took out uh the lady with them tot
carl
oh honey i called the tits she came out
to the show and uh man
oh my god yeah what
she met a man because of us yes some
guys slid into her dms and now they
live together what yeah chin
you're not here but you [ __ ] up dude
that could have been you no
chin didn't mess up he had a wife or
whatever that little lady is who's
always
sick or something he said and then yeah
they didn't work out and now
the girl met somebody wow good looking
dude normal dude
i didn't see him i think he was an
alcoholic and i'm not judging him i
didn't meet him i'm just guessing it's
also at my show
yeah so i have two people there yeah
wow what a love story half the people at
my show were definitely relapsing
yeah now here's again battery though
good for her man oh
yeah she was she pretty in person
beautiful lady
nice head nice shirt
oh how about stevia can you come in
today he goes bro on a plane to
washington see that girl gave me the
hickey
oh really you're disgusting she he told
me that she
she sucked syrup out of his neck i was
like what
like right through his skin he said gosh
just sipping sucrose right out that
little siamese twin
he could have a little baby on the way i
could have a little baby
[ __ ] you i could have a baby i gotta
have a baby i got so much
he said i got so much [ __ ] last weekend
yeah he's disgusting we got a king
interesting
i mean
the heart's doing it what is this autism
and why are they in spandex dude
actually these dudes are
going yeah they are
king of sting at medieval times indoor
all year round
tournament sword fighting and jousting
or the outdoors renaissance fair let me
know gang gang
buzz buzz wow wow dude that's awesome
bro
it's cool you're been immediate maybe
paul giamatti
a little bit actually he looks like lil
alzado a little
oh he looks at that lollipop when he was
sick he looks like
lyla zado giamatti
uh a little bit louder zado
yeah that's when he was sick that's what
i'm talking about yeah he looks similar
oh yeah he was like the first person to
get cancer ever
you got a throat cancer i think and then
light and then blamed on steroids and
was like
i don't know dude it probably was that
he did he also
fought uh muhammad ali maha stadium
boxing no way
did he lose no he went the distance what
he was a good boxer
yeah i had like over 100 amateur fights
they said the logan paul of his time
going the distance with the greatest
yeah they've been doing this forever
yeah go back and see that
is that true lyle alzado and muhammad
ali yep
you think it was a real fight oh yeah
but it was like
you know muhammad ali was a lot older
man and they thought
they did at milo stadium in denver
because they thought it would like sell
out and it did not sell out
how old are you that's probably a huge
deal in denver
i guess not if it didn't it wasn't it
didn't sell well
it was like on [ __ ] nbc too do you
remember this when you were a kid
no wow no not at all
a couple good shots he landed decently
but yeah this was
tail end of muhammad ali he was old man
wow that's crazy man
different time different times uh i'm
thinking middle evil times are
renaissance fair
renaissance fair the one thing i'll say
about wren faires
legs man the turkey legs are disgusting
those dinosaur turkey legs they're
disgusting i've never seen a turkey that
big they're huge
legs man dude the turkeys that i've seen
are not walking around like that these
are some
thoughts dude those turkeys that they're
singing they're from
obviously mississippi they're from yeah
they're definitely medieval times though
when you first get your
this is dope hour and a half later like
when the [ __ ] this and dude
yeah you got to have alcoholism and also
what they do is there's a lot of up
sales at medieval times man it's like
do you want the ring ceremony do you
want the you know
will uh here's a plastic sword or stab
your son
you know what i'm saying we'll have
somebody sneak up and throw somebody out
of the balcony you can only have
rotisserie chicken
and i'm like can i get something else
like it's medieval times like all right
give me a refill on that pepsi
yeah and it's like oh everything comes
in a wooden flask yeah
wooden tank like little cop mug
yeah wooden mug is there one close no
it's pretty far no and i this time i'll
say this though medieval times i like it
it's almost like you
what ren faire you can hear people like
people are doing stuff but they're also
arguing about
drugs they were doing last night and
stuff like oh welcome to the
sewing place you know yeah i like it and
then they're like oh you [ __ ] owe me
for some grams you know
like there's a lot of like hot beef on
the grill going between the people i
like that chaos
yeah that there's a lot more medieval
hoodness yeah there's a lot more
medieval chaos you can go behind the
scenes of [ __ ] and see people shooting
up and doing all kinds of dope in the
woods sucking each other off and
everything the one guy in the dragon
suit just getting sucked off
it's a lot more medieval it's actually
just
more evil kind of yeah it's more evil
than any good times
it's more depressing times no one's
doing well
no no it's a lot of people with rope
burn
sunburn a lot of huge dudes with
sunburns yeah big dudes
farmer tan yeah a lot of freaking
gingers too it's where a lot of
gingers go a lot of ginger girls with
braids to escape
society is wren fairs or they found out
a way to get paid once a year
from they took larp way too serious and
they'll tit
up man i mean you can find tits on
everything there has tits on it
yeah including the turkey leg look at
this guy in the back of this photo
though
look at him you know that yeah on the
right
the dude is obviously has a chewing
feeding trough on the front of his
thing so he can eat out of that little
dish
this guy looks out of place a little bit
let's zoom in on that guy that's
as close as i can go oh unbelievable
apple
yeah who is that that could be stevie
yeah stevie
also i'm going to say this man you flew
back to see the girl
on southwest whoa
i'll be on southwest tomorrow but
dude here was the best thing ever
david's paid the other day went to
mcdonald's and eight
inside in nashville out dope is that
really yeah were people harassing him
no i'm just some dude came over he said
i'm like a dude or a homeless
person i was like are you david spady
and a mcflurry right now dude
dude the mcdonald's in our hometown like
one had like a nintendo 64 you could
play yeah and there was a fireplace
i was excited to go to mcdonald's it was
like [ __ ] yeah that was the [ __ ]
the ball pit the ball pit that the play
area yeah
there was always an airplane that [ __ ]
yeah it was like a centerpiece that like
you could sit around and have your meal
and it was like a
a big mac and a fireplace dude somebody
having a baby
you get fired on i feel like a lot of
mcdonald's in mcdonald's is definitely
it's getting ratchet it's gotten a
little bit
me ghost did you know a guy who lived in
a ball pit or something
oh dude when we first moved here me and
my buddy paul we slept in the ball pit
over on wilshire
oh that sounds terrible anytime your
buddy would move it'd make all the noise
all the balls that goes
off yeah the big move hey paul
quit moving dude get settled yeah yeah
that was the biggest the hardest part
in the float tank and you just have to
keep moving down to get through all the
walls
and this is kind of comfy though huh oh
it was cozy the bottom is cozy the
problem is you don't realize how much
hair and coins is in there no i realize
it
and there's bacteria everywhere because
he can't clean those balls
no one's spraying the balls down we're a
bunch of snotty nosed kids just
spreading all that [ __ ] all over thank
you it is it's a pool of [ __ ] disease
man
well it's b it's definitely like their
own little [ __ ] mick wuhan out there
and i'll also say this uh that the third
night we slept in there dude we would go
at night and jump over the fence and
[ __ ] sleep in there and then leave
early
there was an asian guy sleeping on the
slide in there oh
just on the slide yeah we didn't know
like we're in there being loud he's like
quiet down
if you're gonna be in here pipe down hey
guys what's up it's such-and-such from
somewhere california
i have a king here to sting it for you
today it's uh using psychedelic
mushrooms
for anxiety depression uh
there's a lot of benefits it can be used
for if you micro dose it
we just started growing it we got our
grain spawn right here
and then we have our agar plates full of
mycelium
um basically my wife has really really
bad anxiety
so she just microdoses on these
mushrooms and
gets real trippy it makes her feel
better no more anxiety
less stress just easier for her and
better for her to live her life
let me know what you guys think uh love
the show thank you for having me
yeah yeah but we take a bunch of
mushrooms maybe the anxiety's gone but
she's seeing like gargoyles in the
corner and [ __ ]
like is that her day no no burning you
have to you don't know about mushrooms i
don't
have gunshrooms huh have you done drugs
no have you done them
he's talking about micro dosing you take
like a small amount i've i've heard
microdosing like if you do like adderall
christian they say uh microdosings
similar but without all the symptoms
evaderal yeah how do you mic
how would you micro how did you do that
i don't know dude yeah
dude don't ask questions first of all
don't ask me questions those are his
arch nemesis okay the drugs are my
archnemesis
ask the attic over here about the drums
yeah
keloid have you done them before what's
your name christian sorry have you done
them
shrooms yeah uh yeah once okay it didn't
really have
any effect on me really like it didn't
take enough no i took a lot i thought
like i was gonna see
like i thought a couch would be talking
to me or something everything just
seemed uh
slow brighter and i just felt like a
little happier
yeah you get the yawns a little bit with
shrooms you get those shroomy yawns
i'll say this i did him one time with my
buddy growing up and he turned into the
only chinese kid that ever lived in our
town
we had some stout batches dude we used
to get them fresh
off of the field oh hot off the menu is
that where they get them from underneath
the manure
yeah some of them right yeah like some
of the spores i think that there's like
a fertilization process that happens
with like between manure
and um i think something that's already
in the garden i know for a lot of like
military guys and ufc guys when they
do show signs of ct they're recommending
micro dosing
oh it's huge now supposed to help with
your brain i see more people that are
you'll see people out at night that are
on mushrooms and not on anything else
and they're normal
yeah and there's no and is there there's
no side effects next morning uh i went
the other night with my friend and he
was on him and
i didn't know what was going on and then
suddenly i was
like the faces he was making weren't
didn't fit with whatever was going on
like we're actually at spades comedy
show and he's like this
and i'm like dude what why don't your
face match with what we're looking at
yeah and then
and he's like i'm having a great time
yeah and he said that he said he was on
mushrooms
somebody also had a baby seat at david
spade show the other night so that was a
little bit weird
but um i feel like you've done mushrooms
nick i really like mushrooms i've only
probably done it
10 to 15 times
for over 15 years but
recent here is p.o freaking laughing as
he said that about
recently i i ate some and
my girlfriend's friend's fiance he makes
chocolates of him he sells them in bars
but i ate some when i was watching ufc
fight
and jules came in the room and i was
just like washing the fight with my hand
on my knees like
you were really into it you're sweating
yeah and she said i look like this lady
giving corner
she's a mean is that nelly yeah but did
you look like you had anxiety is the
question yeah you're giving corner
advice
[Laughter]
but uh yeah they're fun look man i'm all
for it i think there's definitely some
some great pathways to good things going
on out there there's a company now
called compass that's the first um
i think they are like a like a
it's almost like a marijuana like
distillery but for mushrooms
that's on the new york stock exchange
now so like they're definitely gaining
uh
traction amongst like regular just if it
can help it's a natural product who
gives a [ __ ]
totally dude especially when you have
people on all this other [ __ ] people
getting
people popping opioids somebody's cat
ate an opioid the other day and they
caught it [ __ ] it jumped in front of
a
the l train or something in new york all
the [ __ ] that's going on like
it's good to see like some natural stuff
getting uh getting out there
i'm all for it man i'll be down for that
micro dosing yeah
i um if it's legit i don't wanna get it
from my [ __ ]
kyle over there you know i need some
legit [ __ ] yeah i think there's ways
like yeah and i think it's definitely
there's ways to use stuff where it's
like
you're just trying to party and then
there's ways to use stuff where it's
like you're trying to figure out things
that could help you
you know i used to think mike rowdosing
was tripping with the guy from dirty
jobs
that's awesome
i could see that dude i tweeted that
once
[Laughter]
and how did it go uh not a lot
come for the gang buzz stay for the
second hand jokes
that's all right second hand jokes that
should be the name of our whole podcast
and here's a guy right here who's living
in his car what's up dickie dion
fat boy it's uh cj i'm from california
when i was younger i had to get surgery
looking for a long-lost testicle oh yeah
unfortunately
[Laughter]
unfortunately they couldn't find it so
i got that king of the stingy a one nut
hitter
let me know why does this mustache match
his eyebrows
it looks like he took his eyebrows and
moved him to his mustache
they're the exact same dude he's got
that magical look like that
uh mr whatever will you drag the man's
face around with a little stick yeah
uh i think it was called face ronnie or
something
i mean his eyebrows match his mustache
that thing called where you make the
little
you can make him look a towel you know
whatever move it yeah yeah
i forget what the wooly willy wooly
willy yeah we had the
cheaper one too called face ronnie look
that one up
and that one was [ __ ] somebody got
stabbed while we looked at it i remember
yeah that's old school man dude have you
guys seen somebody send me a link of
somebody named um
oh man i can't hear what it was now
music link oh shob calan shaub
have you seen that oh he's an artist is
it yeah we've got that for years oh yeah
i have i thought that i
just like it oh yeah he's like he's like
i guess a big time artist i don't know
but his name is
yeah that's cool that's awesome it's
weird huh
uh okay what else do we have to do
[Laughter]
this guy's got a debate club oh this is
obviously me
okay king and the sting what's up
got a debate club for you helen keller
was she real i think that [ __ ] was
lying
gang gang buzz buzz now this is an
increasingly popular conspiracy on the
internet what really
that she she didn't exist or i could see
that
there's just no way that could happen
but uh it's also a
very easily disprovable conspiracy
theory because she like wrote a book and
she was
yeah a person i went to she has a house
i actually went by her house
pretty well documented in connecticut uh
and this is probably uh six months ago
she has a house where did she live at if
you see helen keller
he wrote an entire [ __ ] book
adolescent home no
i mean alabama no uh
yeah to to scumbia alabama
but she she died in easton county that's
where i went to
connect so i went to her death home look
fam i'll say this if you deaf
blind dumb mentally handicapped [ __ ]
start a podcast yeah yeah
dude the best of the people sometimes
and it's it's nice but it's definitely
wild like
somebody's like dude i'm making a new
podcast man you know it's for people
that were injured in uh
on in horse accidents you know love to
have you on the fifth episode
it's just like bro what
hard pass yeah dude hey man
me and my buddy thomas uh who died
actually we're doing a we're doing a
podcast on surfing injuries
yeah yeah it's a ouija board only man
it's way intense
it's hella we shoot it out of my house
you're welcome to come over it's any
tuesday and it's like
what what time whatever time works for
you man
and here's thomas from gray block pizza
and i'm just joking but they have
similar hair
uh he's got a debate club yo what's up
brendan and theo this is mike from okc
see i got the authentic march on brenden
i know you call people out for that
uh you know i love watching ufc [ __ ]
fake fake merch
we just did the theo before the show and
then somehow mark from iowa had the same
yeah a lot of stolen valor out there
we should do some stolen balor episodes
sorry people are wearing faces
and fake [ __ ] man uh you know i love
watching the ufc fights the heavyweight
men go at it but i got a king of stinger
for you guys
when we gonna see them heavyweight women
go at it huh
i want to know man we got to see two 300
pound women duking it out
okay call donna tell them pay them girls
tell them they need a whole new weight
class a whole new belt
okay bigger belt okay heavyweight women
going at it
call donna tell them
gang gang buzz buzz peter man donna you
know that
i mean there's just not a market for it
you know it's just what
are you telling me if we didn't start
those fights
right now there's not a marketplace
there's a market raise your hand if
you'd watch it in here no we all would
okay
well that's a mark now that for for the
king of the sting fight club that we
could definitely you know call lizzo up
to get
partake in the hell i want to see
brittany griner versus uh
who else who could she fight um
they're struggling to get 140 fighters
you know over 145 he gets sloppy he
thinks
he's sloppy nah there's some heart he's
not a lot of big girls chelsea lynn's a
pretty she's a thicker gal
she could fight britney grinder i think
i would like i would definitely like to
chelsea's athletic too i think she used
to skateboard herself man
huh some pride that's that pride style
them big boys or i'd watch uh
caitlyn jenner fight um brittany griner
that'd be funny
you really want to see her in the
octagon usually yeah brittany grinder
she belong in lanky doug is that your
wife man look everybody has to you know
we have to adapt
so overcome is that do you want a man
huh is that you want a man i don't know
what her end goals are
[Laughter]
but she's afraid yeah she just had her
sixth dunk i think together i'd love to
see you get a shot off against her
chris yeah dude i bet you couldn't even
nut around her if you freaking had 10
minutes i bet you wouldn't even she
would
freaking bat every freaking thing you
tried away everything dude you're
disgusting
yeah you're gross
i was talking to myself uh so we got to
please know that i really was
we got some more cats in the wild oh
this hat either fits or doesn't
[ __ ] make your mind up this thing is
aggravating
uh someone dm'd me this uh sorry i don't
know who it is but it was brendan
getting engaged with brendan
whose birthday is it whose birthday is
it who's birthday
it's the same guy
big brown and little brown dog
crew and the j stands for jerky enough
that [ __ ] is crazy bro and beautiful
man right there too happy holidays to
those guys
uh and then it's hilarious a couple
weeks ago we had
uh theo he was having a good time at a
concert and someone saw him in another
concert in nashville just wilding out
oh god
oh my god is that cat's merch
bro where's this at uh some gergington
kentucky or tennessee or something
that's scotland
look everybody else is just relaxing
dude he's doing the back strokes
bobby lee when he relapsed
[Laughter]
that definitely looks like him i can't
believe bobby's
brother flew up to washington
to double down he can't do the show on
that hickey he's trying to double down
that hickey man things started to go
away he wasn't feeling it
unbelievable man i'm gonna go see that
little sucker fish up in washington
flying southwest man went up there to
see that little freaking
korean piranha i told myself you're too
good for the greyhound huh all right
another people are really getting
attached to old beef tongs uh we got
another one
when he was ready for memorial day
weekend
i got people hit me up going you're
going down to belmar this weekend it's
gonna rain
because it's memorial day weekend i'm
gonna be at dj's
rain snow sleet hell it don't [ __ ]
matter i'm gonna be there
pumping my [ __ ] fist like the jerk
off i am
it is nothing nobody's gonna do about it
all right
pumping my phone
dude what about your boy popeye from uh
the french quarter can you pull him up
i couldn't tell if that guy was autistic
italian yeah i think it's called italian
okay obviously we just made a new word
dude
bro you got to start an instagram page
for italian dude
especially with everybody's west bank
i'm from algiers i'm from avondale from
waggaman i'm from the west bank i roam
that
got all kind of [ __ ] got the glow sticks
i got the
gotcha bag got the hawaiian punch man
everybody won't hide that pop what you
need i got it i got it i found it
that's popeye right there man i didn't
need some micro dosing
dude i think he passed away too oh
really that's surprising yeah
so r.i.p man damn they getting all the
good ones dude
and long neck died did he die longneck
died i thought
boy i think i feel like you would know
he got he knocked up a straw
porn star yeah what porn star had sex
with long and also
porn star is a loose term these people
just torn an actress
all right
somebody that's doing sex in front of a
probably not getting a lot of money for
an artist or a camera yeah
dude when i would yeah there you go
right there oh there she is doug
there he did he put that freaking that
little hand
was all about he put that neck
and what do they say a huge congrats in
order for social media star
damn long neck my boy look at him son
of dawg he looks like every character
from the wedding singer right there
it is awesome i'm here for this
suit and look he's in love too though
man look at her look good for him man
[Music]
he's still hanging out that big fat guy
who's always that guy died i think
ginger
sniffer or whatever his name was and why
neck fought on the card with lamar
at him and uh oh did he did wide neck
win i don't know what happened
i mean look these people
are trolls okay let's be honest
we're loving we do what we can okay
but look i'm beating around the bush
right now look here
[ __ ] ham clitter whatever your name
is dude these people
are trolls all right and they are that's
where we're at
you have trolls fighting each other you
have
lamar odom beating the last of the male
sexuality out of aaron carter okay
that's what you have right as crypto
plunges okay that's what you get
people
oh my god how did they even how is this
not a freaking hate crime
aaron actually came out pretty hot he
came out hot but
he uh he got beat up
but this is so much braver to me i'll
say this aaron carter
what you did is so much braver to me
than what jake paul did
because i feel like you are going up
against
someone that even if you put you guys
next to each other
i mean this dude is beating the last
damn little vicodin out of your [ __ ]
spinal column
this dude is helping you out is there
is there highlights of uh thick or
[ __ ] wide now
it's everything it's wide neck is short
[ __ ] is freaking
narrow tits whatever it's every it's
look
let's do it all it's time brother who's
he fighting
drew
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah this guy's really giving it to him
next got to put his hands up huh
i bet your neck can take a shot though
dude
and it was crazy chuck liddell was the
ref for the lamar odom fight
who's the wreck who is the freaking
guy hold on what rehab is this guy out
of
go back go back 15 seconds watch his
referee marching around
what rehab is this guy
loose from what freaking
what [ __ ] dutch recovery center
it did this dude you lose from watch
this referee move around man
whoa croatian halfway house is
this of mice and men
[ __ ] olympian out of what is going on
here
yeah there's a little bit of he looks a
little bit like crow cobb i see it yeah
i was gonna say that
okay and you owe me 10 hours if you
announce cro cop again i get to
no you guys does he not look like him
nick i
literally i almost said it it's like
brandon how you doing anything when i
thought i grew
up dude i don't even would you for
dinner dude
oh [ __ ] i remember oh my my my bad i
referenced the guy who's like
number one in the world i'm sorry deal
let's talk about you relapsing again man
was he really one number one
yeah he's the number one fighter in the
world at a time
in what did in what conference uh pride
was he really yeah
yeah he's a [ __ ] let's go to
greyhound on twitter nick
what did greyhound be posting oh yeah
they got some
good [ __ ] this [ __ ] is hype anything
guys you can do first of all on our way
from albany new york city and we're just
on the side of the road with a broken
bus
without any announcement from the driver
four people
grounds yeah people out here
i love how they make them stand separate
from each other
[Laughter]
but then they get back on a loaded bun
yeah and then one girl has a cigarette
freaking orangey over there she got that
freaking cigarette
what does this thing say what does that
say please wear a mask
and the driver won't tell him anything
[ __ ] i'm on greyhound go was the least
of my problems
if the driver is nowhere to be found
which lord of the flies leader told him
to stay six feet apart from each other i
don't know all right everybody let's
keep our distance out here
i think it was dark cartman over there
freaking
dropped some knowledge on them okay back
up okay
do you have any employees at work at
this company i've been waiting for a
package for
over one month every phone
[Laughter]
phone calls revie emails literally zero
help or progress
i've been stonewalled the entire
stonewalled
i love how greyhound busts like are bad
man here's the number try calling this
he's like [ __ ] that's the number i've
been calling
my mom sent a package to me on may 24th
the fact is never arrived i was told the
agent never sent the tracking
when i tried to track there's no
information not even a scan
uh when the station just told me it's
not there
yeah i just bought a ticket from the
mexican
greyhound site goddammit brandon
and this is brandon true wong dude
who easily could be your son dude
yeah greyparrow.com dude
you can't buy anything from mexican
greyhound
i want a refund uh here go down a little
bit more here is lee hong
and i'm not gonna say that in that last
name because i don't want to get in
trouble
no hard pass
okay had the absolute worst experience
at greyhound
on monday me and my friend booked a bus
ride from new orleans louisiana
rochester new york
five transfers scheduled the second
transferred the second transfer
was from memphis there were over chicago
100
only 45 you guys means cove is no worry
uh
and this guy goes damn i read this
remind me how lucky i am
somebody's in the gym just getting
pumped by reading these
this ain't my life hell yeah i'm doing
better than these people at least
dude i've been on greyhound man i went
when i was young so much man there was
always a dude on there trying to show
you his dick or leave a note or massage
your feet
meet me in the bathroom at the when we
stopped for gas
well bro i get your first seven notes
[Laughter]
give up bro and then we would get off
the bus and be like hey you get my note
and be like
yeah i got your [ __ ] note a young man
in the second to last roll the seats on
the driver's side is taking a puff of a
cigarette in a few minutes
oh no [ __ ] yeah dude you're on greyhound
you're like it's not [ __ ] crap
yeah dude you're lucky he isn't back
there [ __ ]
lighting his own body parts on fire
you're lucky the bus isn't on fire
[ __ ] he's just trying to get a
little sick
dude the best is their package shipping
they have a shipping service apparently
it sounds awful bro everybody's package
is missing they literally just steal
your packages dude great i was like what
bro
yeah and you go bro they don't care is
that
you to greyhound oh yeah i stay on these
people i'm woke
you're the one that said this makes me
realize that's how good my life is yeah
go back to the voicemail when this is
this is a good one right here so this
lady said there were no agents or
workers at this point in the night and
me and my friend were extremely worried
for our safety
uh while we were on the first transfer a
man was fondling himself across from my
friend
basically she was sexually harassed we
were told by the driver they could do
nothing about it and we needed to exit
the bus
as [ __ ] dude and while and while we were
straining in memphis two sketchy guys
entered the terminal station and tried
to lure me and my friend
into their car for food
at one point one of them was basically
begging my female friend to leave the
terminal
and go outside with him alone and then
she labeled the
recording kidnappers from tennessee and
it was
recording her complaining it's a bla
it's uh
two guys trying to lure them outside
she added her their contact
he's like hey mama let me what you got
in them shorts it's a [ __ ] like that
bro graham sounds like a nightmare
pretty hard to sleep over there
[Music]
he said i got my american eagle drawls
on girl he goes you got them little
american eagle draws on girl
the best lure them into their car for
some food
i mean i love how we're spending all
this money on sex trafficking
and it's basically just shut down
greyhound everyone's all good
dude you're yeah unbelievable
some guys jerking off in the seat and
they made
them get off the bus you have to get up
in here and do [ __ ] about it yeah like
oh you got a problem with people
jerking off on the coach oh i'm sorry do
you have a problem
with our friend over there jacking up in
front of you
yeah what's wrong with you guys y'all
are racist we're gonna have to ask
is that it that's it dope dope dope damn
um we'll start doing spots in l.a now
this [ __ ] is open july
16th 17th i'm at hahas meeting some
friends at haha's comedy club
that's in los angeles california
and then the big one san antonio
september 26
and 27th san antonio a t
gang man um i got some new dates that
are up we just put an extra cincinnati
show up oh
uh we put an extra durum show up in
extra chattanooga and knoxville
uh and we still got
uh an extra minneapolis show we added
portland maine
and burlington vermont and we also added
a charleston
and uh doug and an albany and a columbus
so all those are up at theovon.com tour
and make sure to go get tickets there
because
the other sites people fake them man
it's like them are they up charging me
up
yeah wherever you get any tickets for
any comedy shows make sure it's through
the comedian's website
because that's legit there's no up
charges yeah because otherwise when
people hit me i'm like dude i just paid
900
for a ticket i'm like you're an idiot i
paid 900 now i'm on a greyhound head to
albany new york
yeah some guy's jacking off man is this
the vip ticket
things are looking up someone just
offered me food in their car
the last we hear from a lot of people
man staff them greyhounds man they off
them greyhounds baby you guys be
good gang gang brennan and theo fighter
and weight i got to go in and go hard in
the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you